[Music]
this morning a special edition of the
dish with Bruce and Eric Bromberg their
Blue Ribbon restaurant Empire got its
start 25 years ago this fall with the
original Blue Ribbon Brasserie here in
New York considered a cradle of today's
culinary scene it was a hangout for some
then-unknown chefs who would go on to
become some of the biggest restaurant
tours in the world I recently sat down
with the founders and tasted the
timeless appeal of Blue Ribbon all right
so this is a little trifecta of
definitely fun food at blue you're
definitely using some fingers and kind
of having fun from fondue to pupu
platter
to their famous fried chicken Eric and
Bruce Bromberg say the secret to Blue
Ribbon is a brotherly love of eating
ever since we were young
ribs were just like always the highlight
for me so it's just a situation of let's
make things that we love there you go
the chef's behind this finger food were
actually classically trained at La
Cordon Bleu in Paris but they found
cooking in three-star restaurants far
from satisfying one of the things that
really struck me was none of my friends
could come to those restaurants they
were so expensive so exclusive but why
don't we just take the technique of fine
cooking let's apply it to everything we
learned and let's make it accessible to
everyone they opened the Blue Ribbon
Brasserie on Sullivan Street in Soho on
November 3rd 1992 Kimball Cramer showed
up just a few days later he's been
coming back up to five times a week ever
since I saw a new restaurant walked in
and liked it
food was outstanding I was looking for a
hangout place and I knew I had found it
it all began in this you know tiny
little hole in the wall this was two
apartments that we joined together and
you know kind of had this idea of just
making a good restaurant they started
with a simple notion what is blumerman
its first prize it's the best things it
sounded American the translation of
cordon bleu is Blue Ribbon so it all
kind of came together it was more of an
idea and I think that's what Blue Ribbon
meant to us it was this concept it was
this heart and soul of everything we had
done growing up as kids you used to
actually play restaurant
we played restaurant but we pretty much
just played Benihana was back in the
Benihana that hold constant being and
seeing a chef in front of us was just
the coolest thing in the world and we'd
always try to order shrimp cocktail
which our dad never let us do and it has
been a special at Blue Ribbon for 25
years just because of the special every
single by the Bromberg's credit their
father an attorney for their insatiable
appetite it was always about that next
meal summer camp in Maine there were
stops along the way where it was you
know pizzas in New Haven and clam
chowder at this place and the lobster at
this place
where are we going in Chinatown in New
York where do you get the best egg roll
where do you get the best fun do you
know like everything was about the meal
but as they were getting ready to open
Blue Ribbon
there was one key ingredient missing we
didn't really know what the menu was
gonna be and at one point literally a
couple days before opening Eric's wife
Ellen was like guys we need to print
menus we need like lists you know what
are you doing Blue Ribbon which stayed
open till 4:00 in the morning would
become a late-night hangout for
up-and-coming chefs coming off their
shifts it was that time when the entire
culinary scene was giving birth in a
sense and the group of people whether it
was Danielle and his team or Bobby and
his team Mario Mario was the sous chef
at a local Italian place he had just
moved from Sea
and he was come in every single night
and sit at the bar and we all just hung
out this dish I think resonated with the
chef world more than any other dish it's
the beef marrow and oxtail marmalade
that they would eat in Paris they call
them Oh some wall and we would look at
each other and be like this is
ridiculous it's better than foie gras
but we had never heard of it before we
hadn't seen it in any books delicious
it's crazy it's one of those wishes it
should never be messed with it yeah we
may never make just sitting here again
and thinking of how many different
people have sat at this table over the
years from you know President Clinton to
Mick Jagger to this chefs that we grew
up learning about NIDA lysing Danielle
or Sean George or any of these people
coming in and saying like this is the
greatest place I've ever been to and
we're like it wasn't like this I've ever
had right it wasn't that it was that
they saw something different in blue
ribbon there was something different
going on here that's something different
helped the Bromberg's
turn blue ribbon Brasserie into the blue
ribbon Empire operating 20 restaurants
from fried chicken to sushi
around the country over the last 25
years so is this more fun than the
Benihana is kids having this this is
more adult fun eating like this is I
think ultimately what makes us really
happy and thankfully it makes some other
people happy too started as a family
affair still is and you can taste the
love in their food I love that they
played restaurant as killer Lee they
played Benihana